So I'm going to talk to you today about
a different way of looking at what real
is.
It's not easy to figure out what real is
because we don't really have infinite
knowledge and so we're always making
some sets of presuppositions about
what's most real and really matters what
you assume is most real because you base
the decisions that you make that run the
entire course of your life on those
assumptions,
whether you recognize it or not,
and if you get the assumptions wrong or
even if you leave them in complete,
you're going to pay a big price for it.
And,
uh,
the assumptions that we use in our
culture,
although they've enabled us to develop a
tremendously potent technology,
are incomplete in ways that have also
cost us in,
that are extremely dangerous.
Since the scientific age began.
We've lived in a universe where the
bottom strata of reality is considered
to be something that's dead like dirt.
It's like it's matter,
it's objective,
it's
external,
and there isn't any element of it that
lends any reality to phenomena like
meaning or purpose.
That's all been relegated to this
objective.
And in some ways to the illusory,
but it's by no means self evident that
that set of presuppositions is correct
because we lack infinite knowledge and
there's many things about the structure
of being that we don't understand the
main one being consciousness.
We can't account for it at all and we
can't account for the role it appears to
play in the transformation of potential
into actuality,
which is a role that's been recognized
by physicists for almost 100 years now.
And which remains one of the biggest
unsolved mysteries in science.
There are other ways of looking at
what's real
and these other ways have some
advantages and one of the advantages
they have is that they protect us
knowing these other ways of operating
within reality.
Defining reality protect us from certain
kinds of pathologies.
And modern people are prone to a fair
number of pathologies that stem from the
assumptions of their,
of their,
of the systems they use to define
reality.
And one of those pathologies is a kind
of a nihilistic hopelessness,
which is a consequence of the
recognition that in the final analysis
nothing really has any meaning.
And because life is difficult and that's
a meaning that you can't escape,
being forced to abandon your belief in a
positive or a meaning can leave you
week,
the times when you really can least
afford to be weak and there's more
important pathologies that it's opened
us up to two.
And those are pathologies of belief.
And I think we saw the most horrifying
examples of that.
Hopefully the most horrifying examples
in the 20th century where people whose
belief systems were shattered,
at least in part by the competition
between religious and scientific
viewpoints,
turned in large numbers to mass
movements that were in error in every
way as substitute,
a moral rational in some sense
substitute for religious beliefs that
appeared no longer tenable.
And the consequences of that was it was
just about annihilation.
Because we came close to annihilation
twice,
once in the sixties and once in the
eighties.
And even without the totality of
annihilation,
we lost hundreds of millions of people
as a consequence of pathological belief
systems in the 20th century.
So if belief systems become
pathological,
they po that pathology can pose the
biggest threat possibly to our very
existence.
And if you're a Darwinian in any sense,
you have to understand that the things
that pose the biggest threats to your
survival are the most real things they
have to be dealt with.
Now,
here's another way of looking at things.
I'll start with the definition of this
word.
This word famous thigh is the root word
of phenomenon,
phenomenon and phenomena are the things
that appear to you and famous by means
to shine forth and the phenomenologists
who were interested in,
in the shining forth of things made the
presumption that the things that
manifested themselves to you as most
meaningful word,
the most real things.
And I think you can make a strong case
that that's actually how your brain is
wired.
Because your brain is wired to react to
things that have meaning before they
construct the perceptions that you think
of as objects.
And the reason for that is because the
meaning of things is more real in some
sense,
but more important than the view of
things as objects.
And so,
for example,
a famous philosopher,
psychologist,
division said that when you approach a
cliff,
you don't see a cliff,
you see a falling off place.
It isn't that it's an object cliff to
which you attribute the meaning of
falling off place too.
It's the falling off place.
Perception comes first,
and the abstraction of the objective
cliff,
if it ever happens at all,
it comes much later,
much later conceptually,
because even babies can detect cliffs
and much later,
historically,
poets have noticed this phenomenon
shining forth reality and they've often
associated with childhood.
And I think there's good reasons for
that.
I think your brain is not so much of an
inhibitory structure when you're a child
before it's fully developed.
And
so there's,
there's neurological reasons for noting
it,
but there's also reasons that stem from
the level of lived experience you can
tell when you're around children,
that they're open things in a way that
adults aren't there wide eyed with
wonder and adults like being around
children for that reason.
Because although the child takes an
awful lot of care and is,
uh,
is a,
a terrifying object in some ways to
behold if you have a relationship with
the child because they're so vulnerable,
the part of the way they pay you back is
they open up your eyes,
your eyes that have been closed by your
experience and that have learned to
shield out the things that shine forth.
And when you have a child,
you can look through the child's eyes
again.
And to me it's like they're on fire in a
sense.
They're like a candle or something
that's burning brightly.
And I think that's also partly because
we actually don't screen out fire.
We actually see fire and that's why we
can't not look at it when it's around.
I think the same thing happens when
you're in love with someone,
if it's,
if it's genuine love,
because genuine love gives you a hint of
what could be in the future.
If you could just set yourself right,
you get a glimpse of what could be in
the future.
If you fall in love with someone,
you don't get that without work,
but you get a glimpse of it,
and I think it's because when you fall
in love,
and I believe this is likely a
biochemical transformation,
is the perceptual structures that
normally stop you from seeing people
because you really don't see people.
You just see shadows.
They did that,
that that the barriers are lifted
temporarily and what's really there
shines through and it's overwhelming,
but to stay in that state,
well,
it requires a tremendous amount of moral
effort is really the right way of
thinking about it.
Words were said about children.
There was a time when meadow grove and
stream the earth and every common sight
to me did seem appareled in celestial
light.
The glory and the freshness of a dream
it is not now as it has been of your
turn,
were soever.
I may by night or day,
the things which I have seen I now can
see no more earth fills her lap with
pleasures of her own yearnings.
She have in her own natural kind and
even with something of a mother's mind
and no unworthy aim.
The homely nurse doth all she can to
make her foster child,
her inmate man.
Forget the glories he hath known and
that Imperial Pellets Palace whence he
came.
And what he means by this is that as you
develop as an as a,
as a competent adult,
which which is precisely the.
The direction towards which you should
develop,
much of what you're doing is actually
closing in and narrowing your closing in
and narrowing towards a particular goal
in a particular way of being.
And that's necessary because as you
develop,
you have to develop towards a particular
way of being.
Or you don't develop it all and you can
stay a child forever.
That goes,
that goes sour of its own accord and so
human beings are destined to close their
perceptions in to sharpen themselves and
to focus on very little so that they can
at least do that.
But the price we pay for that is that we
start to replace the relationship we
have with untrammeled reality,
with the shadows that are only complex
enough to let us do what we need to do
and no more.
And in some sense,
although we become more competent in
other ways,
we've become more blind and we kind of
know how this happens.
That happens from the bottom up.
Now this is the Greek painting and the
painting as an obvious meaning in a
sense which is that we're blinded even
to what's right in front of us by the
objects that we see and we think that
seeing is letting in the light,
but it's only letting in a very small
fraction of the light because we're only
capable of contemplating a small
fraction of everything whenever we're
doing any particular thing.
And so very much of what we're doing is
screening things out.
Very much of your cortex is inhibitory
and the greed is trying to get at that
with that idea.
It's like there's a businessman there,
he's dressed in his uniform.
He can't see beyond the immediate,
the immediate thing that's in front of
his eyes.
How does that happen?
Well,
let's say you're a baby.
The first thing you learn,
you learn.
You build your body from the bottom up,
your build,
your perceptual and actual structures
from the bottom up.
You learn to move your arm,
you learned to close your hand.
Then you learn to do things that are
practical with those abilities.
You lift the spoon while you have to do
that to feed yourself.
You learn to move a plate.
You learn to set the table that's
starting to become social now because
you can set the table for you and for
other people.
You learn to make a meal.
That's a more complex sequencing of
motor activities and perceptual
abilities that's very focused.
As you continue to develop the things
you chained together become more and
more complex and and but also more
specific.
You have to care for your family,
which means there's all sorts of other
things you're not doing.
You have to find a good job,
which almost everyone,
when they're young experiences as the
contemplation of limitation.
Well not everyone,
but many people think,
oh no,
you know,
I'm going to have to settle for this
role.
I don't want to only be that role,
but it's better to be that role that no
role at all,
and maybe the way through the role to
the other side is through the role,
don't want around it.
There's no avoiding the responsibility
of narrowing and shaping and
specializing.
Be a good parent.
Well that's the sacrifice you make for
the next generation.
Be a good partner.
The same thing,
be a good citizen.
It's easy for young people in particular
to be skeptical of that because the old
society is always corrupt and archaic
and blind to become a member of.
That seems to be in part two to allow
yourself to adopt that same agent
blindness,
but that thing also educates you.
It shapes every word you speak.
It's something that you have to be
grateful to even in its agent,
an archaic form and it's part of the
necessities of human responsibility that
you become a good citizen
and that means
in some sense,
giving up more of what could be at least
to sustain.
What is
is a satirical song from the late
eighties,
nineties,
English.
I am the very model of a modern major
general of information,
vegetable,
animal and mineral.
I know the kings of England and I quote
the fights historical from marathon to
waterloo in order categorical and the
satire.
He as well,
he has the knowledge.
He's an official functionary and it's
very difficult to do that,
but in the same way it's very limited in
categorical and of course an artists
would object to that,
but it's better than nothing at all and
that's the alternative.
Well above that,
maybe what's above good citizen because
sometimes good citizen is not so good if
you were a good citizen of Nazi Germany
or a good citizen of the Soviet Union or
of Mao's China,
you know you were narrowed in a
particular way,
but
and then maybe an unnecessary way,
but also in a very pathological way.
And so it seems to be that there has to
be something even though adopting that
restricted viewpoint is necessary.
There has to be something above it.
And I think that's also the thing that
can restore the sense you have of a true
entanglement with the deepest and most
meaningful realities of life.
And that's the issue of being a good
person.
It's above being a citizen.
It's something else that has something
to do with the development of
individuality.
And I think we're also wired for that.
So it looks like we're wired to lose
what we had to specialize,
but then once we're specialized to
reopen,
once we've got the skills built into our
body and then can handle handle reality
because we're more adapted and more
fluid and more flexible than we can.
Start opening the doors again and I,
and I believe that your nervous system
is set up to help you do that.
If you don't interfere with it.
If you notice and you notice that by
paying attention to the things that
manifest themselves to you,
that shine forth as interesting,
they grab you and where you're grabbed
is where the obscuring map you live in
isn't obscuring the reality that's
underneath.
It's like there's a hole in the map and
the light shines through that and you're
attracted to that and that will pull you
along and that's when your interest is
seized by something that's your nervous
system doing that.
You don't do that.
It's,
it's an unconscious force.
You could even say it was the world
itself talking to you and the
phenomenologists didn't feel that way
and it's a real phenomenon.
It's not a secondary thing and you know
that because you can't live without it.
You Die.
He stultify you get cynical,
you get nihilistic or you adopt some
wild belief system if you don't have the
attachment to some genuine life giving
meaning in your own life and it's a hard
thing to follow that because it doesn't
necessarily put you into perfect
juxtaposition with society because it's
not society.
It's not being a good citizen.
It's something else.
It's also the thing that rebuilds how
you would be a good citizen.
The Egyptians knew about this a long
time ago.
They didn't really know.
They knew
because they acted things out and drama
and portrayed them mythologically
because they didn't have the capacity to
articulate the ideas fully,
but the Egyptians worshiped the human
eye and they worshiped the eye because
they knew the I was the thing that paid
attention like we're really visual
creatures and your eyes automatically
attracted to the things that manifest
themselves or shine forth in front of
you and you have to look at them.
Okay.
If you pay attention
to the things that shine forth because
what you're seeing is the reality.
Instead of the map,
you're gaining access to the real
information that's in the world.
It's not prepackaged information because
that can be forced.
It's the real information flowing up
from the ground of being and if you pay
attention to that,
it will help you move towards the goals
that you've already established for
yourself as a good citizen that are,
that are part of the inbuilt value
structure that you've adopted.
But at the same time it will do
something else.
It will lead you to transform the nature
of those goals because as you pursued
the thing that guides your interest and
more and more information is revealed.
Then by absorbing that information which
is learning,
essentially you build yourself into a
different person,
a stronger and more informed person and
a more,
a more intact person,
a person with more integrity and with
more straight than with more direction,
and at the same time you differentiate
your map and so you're living more and
more in the real world,
so as you approach your specific goal,
even if it's a culturally conditioned
goal,
the learning that you do along the way
transforms you and it transforms the
nature of your goal.
Things shine forth.
There's a reason for that and you know
that because when you're attending to
something you're interested in and
you're engaged in,
that's when you're alive.
That's when life is worthwhile.
It's so worthwhile that in those moments
you don't even ask the question about
the question itself goes away because
the meaning that you're united with is
so powerful that it can push back the
adversity that would otherwise
characterize life.
Nisha said,
the person who has a why can bear anyhow
and and that's a really useful thing to
know because you think,
well,
we're very vulnerable creatures in our
life ends catastrophic and and and
terrible things happen,
and how can we bear that in?
The answer to that is and always has
been that you have to be in sync with
something that's beyond you because that
synchrony gives you the strength that
you need to bear your terrible
limitations.
You see this played out.
People know this.
Everyone knows this.
It's just that our culture isn't good at
articulating it.
We've lost a lot of this.
We haven't developed their knowledge
about this as much as we've developed
our knowledge of the objective world and
we're paying for it.
You see it in weird places on the,
on the right here,
there's an old symbol at the bottom.
It's called the round chaos.
When the alchemists believed that the
round chaos was the thing that held,
what was,
what the world was ultimately made up,
the thing that was most real and they
conceptualize it as something like
inflammation.
They thought about it.
There's a combination of spirit and
matter and it was a combination of
spirit and matter,
which is what information is in a sense
because when you interacted with it,
you took some of the information and you
built yourself out of it,
so that was the spiritual element and
you took some of the information and you
built the world out of it and that was
the material element and they thought of
the reality itself is something that
preceded the spiritual and the material
and that that reality was what showing
for and that's been dramatized and in
entails modern tales of transformation.
The most interesting places popped up is
in the Harry Potter stories were central
to the Harry Potter theme is a game
called quidditch and inquisitive,
which is a game.
The way you win the game is by playing a
game that's sort of outside the
quidditch game.
You win the quidditch game by finding
following this thing that beckons this
golden thing that glimmers and moves
around you.
If you catch that,
then you win.
The game is so does your whole team and
inside that is.
It is the resurrection stone.
It's a,
it's a diamond that says it's a jewel.
The idea is that if you follow the thing
that manifests itself to you as
interesting,
it will lead you through adversity,
a lead you to do things that are
difficult and as that happens,
but not beyond your capacity because
it's tempered for that.
What will happen is as you hit yourself
against the world pursuing what you're
interested in,
you'll tap yourself into alignment.
Your molecules,
your structure,
internal structure will become non
contradictory like the internal
structure of a jewel,
which is something that reflects light.
It makes you hard and durable,
unable to bear the terrible conditions
of existence without becoming corrupt.
He had said something about this,
we shall not cease from exploration,
and the end of all our exploring will be
to arrive where we started and to know
the place for the first time
and that's five line summary of the most
remarkable elaboration of the nature of
the relationship between the individual
human consciousness and reality itself
that's ever been panned.
And and,
and the combination of have a system of
thought that's been developing over
thousands and thousands of years.
Which we have lost and cannot properly
articulate.
I follow what you're interested in.
It'll take you to have adversity and
then through it it'll transform you from
a citizen into an individual and then
the doors will open again and at that
point you're strong enough to have your
life
and at that point you're strong enough
not to fall prey to pathological belief
systems and work towards the destruction
of things.
Thank you.